Okay, welcome everybody to another Zoom call.
Let's get right at it.
I'd like to thank everybody to check the members page.
Our YouTube channel was down.
They pulled our channel for a week.
Dustin talked to them and got it back up.
Actually, it wasn't an issue with anything that we had in our channel this time.
Even though they keep bleeding videos every week.
For medical misinformation, but it was actually somebody hacked our channel and put some other.
Con on financial videos on there.
Bitcoins that they didn't like so they can't send our channel.
So our channel is up and running, but please go to our videos at videos dot cutters clinic dot com.
The link of it is all of our ever cited and websites.
That's where we have all our videos, including the videos that have been deleted by thanks.
So if you have not also set your Instagram settings, you should go in your settings and Instagram because they just updated again last week.
Not telling anybody and you have to agree to see the videos that don't agree with Instagram.
So you have to agree to three settings now on Instagram, where you'll see political videos and you know religious videos and medical misinformation videos.
So you have to go into the settings Instagram and do that.
If you are an Instagram user and you're wondering why don't see videos that I used to see.
It's because Instagram updated their settings updated your settings.
So reminder you can self schedule on our website and on the member site too.
Alright, let's jump into your questions.
I think by six-year-old granddaughter may have age by Laura infection.
She has constant tummy aches.
Can only eat tiny bits before complaining to be false.
Rolls out a little bit with her mouth, which she swallows happened so frequently she doesn't tell you.
But if you ask her her answer is yes, just better.
Frequent constipation with occasional diarrhea her gut seems to be a mess.
I read your blog post at age by Laura and a protocol.
You mentioned that dosages would be different for children.
What would they be for a normal size six-year-old?
Also, how would you convince her parents that she needs or HCL when the conventional hospital website say the exact opposite?
Well, if you have a young person and they have these types of symptoms and you go, you put them on some sort of PPI or even a tongues or a role aids or something like that to help her to be.
They will get some symptomatic relief because it will decrease the answer to the stomach so they'll get less refunds.
But they'll think that they're actually solving their problem but they're actually making their problem far worse.
And setting themselves up for major issues that could haunt their rest of their lives.
So, you know, if their parents are not open to hearing the truth, it's very difficult to do anything.
You can show them my videos, show my blog posts and have them do their own research.
But if they're very medically minded, there's not a lot you can do.
We have family members and our family.
I'm eight out of nine children myself.
And I have some, you know, a couple of my siblings that believed the way I do.
But most of them are extremely medically minded.
Some of them married into, you know, families of nurses or doctors and things.
And they, you know, things that I'm just a total black job.
So it's just the way it is.
And you just get out to live your life the way you want to live.
It's your grandchild. It's very, very difficult.
Most likely does the child have age priori, yes, it's very possible.
But understand with the child, many times you can solve the problem just getting them on HCl.
Maybe just start with apple cider vinegar.
The mother give their daughter apple cider vinegar means for each meal.
A tablespoon of apple cider vinegar. It's a child will take that.
That's going to be acidic enough to balance out of six year olds. God.
So if the mother is not naturally minded at all, they think grandma is crazy.
That it's very difficult to deal with that.
I understand, you know, we have 20s and grandkids and some of them.
We don't see you very often because of, you know, issues.
So, you just got to keep doing everything you can.
Keep sharing the truth and hopefully they'll come around.
But if I did suspect H. But H. Marlora and a six year old and the parents were very compliant.
I would first treat them with HCl or apple cider vinegar.
Because many times that will clear it up.
So you don't need to go to burberry. But quite as if.
If you could get the child.
It's just if the child could swallow pills.
Then it's easy as a child will swallow pills and taking burberry or garlic.
And taking HCl and digestive enzyme.
If they start feeling better, they're going to want to keep taking it and you could clear it up really quick.
I will say though that if you have a six year old with H by Laura,
she's not the only one in the family with it most likely.
So most likely, one of the parents have it as well.
And because H by Laura is a bacterial infection that spreads.
You know, very easily through, you know, kissing it.
It's just very, you know, typically it's rugs in families.
So I would suspect that there's somebody else in the family that probably has it as well.
As far as how much garlic or burberry to take most garlic supplements.
A six year old child could take one of those burberry supplements.
A six year old child could take one of those HCl.
Six year old child could take one with each meal.
They're big enough to take that. Usually there are 50 60 pounds at that side.
At that age, they're big enough to take something like that.
If they're really, really teedy, I'd start with apple cider vinegar.
It's going to be hard to get the child to become quiet.
If the parents are complacent to not agree with it. So it's going to be good.
My doctor is going to put me on a phone call that includes rig beer.
I had a couple questions. I know that at least some programs on the right are antiviral.
I don't know if the program that you get for me includes anything antiviral or none.
And since the rig beer is a virus based, I was wondering if the right could potentially adversely impact the rig beers effectiveness.
I would say yes, the could, but I will say that I've never put viral programs in anybody's overnight.
In any, any cancer patients overnight. So the person came to me and they have, you know, live disease and, you know, multiple, you know, infections and things like that.
I made what a virus program in their overnight, but I've never looked at cancer.
So, we don't have to worry about that.
Is there anything I should otherwise do or not do to optimize the potential benefit?
Just runny your right frequencies on the cancer program is going to help any other therapy attack the cancer better.
So just run with the right frequencies. It's going to be your best bet as much as you possibly do.
The state of good news, the PET scan, all these shows cancer are those two lumps in my left axillary area.
Don't worry about this. That's very good news. I think that they are lumps that lymph nodes not sure, but very glad it's only those small areas.
I'm sure they're going to take care of that. Let's radiation or surgery quickly. I hope.
And we'll be really spreading that.
I want to put vitamin E on my surgical scars as my local practitioner said it is very healing.
Even energetically hearing so that the scars do not cause disturbance to the body.
Designs for health brand that I take every day stains a bright yellow and that's a laundry castle.
Is there any other brand of vitamin E that you'd recommend for this purpose? I know that when you take by mouth, it has to be a certain kind of a need. What should I look for?
Well, the vitamin E that's healing to cancer, the vitamin E that's healing to your arteries is the inner.
So remember vitamin E found in nature is a whole food has four inner parts called.
Tocotryotols and four outer shells called to cough or else.
So, you want it's really the inner parts that are beneficial for the vessels and for cancer.
The outer parts have benefits for your skin. So the cheap form of vitamin E is like alpha to cough or all.
That's what you buy at like, you know, at, you know, Walgreens or something.
And that doesn't work on your vessels.
But in fact, you wouldn't want to use it on your vessels. So I've had patients that have said, showed me their vitamin E bottle. I've been taking this and it's literally alpha to cough or or DL alpha to cough or mix to comforts.
Okay, you could punch a little hole in that capsule and put it on your skin. That's all it's good for.
So it's not good for it to take an oil.
You could use it inexpensive vitamin D like that. That would use that you'd use topic.
I think there's even some vitamin E like sams out there, but they probably don't they probably contain a whole bunch of other junk.
So you could just get some inexpensive alpha to cough or all for your skin that would just fun.
Vitamin E that you're talking about, besides for health is the ADK. You don't need that.
The A and the K for your skin.
My usual banion, botanicals, bulk, turmeric is not available at the moment by a random friend recommended it to me because she says you have to be careful about the lead in purple products.
Do you know if the star was botanicals brand on an Amazon is any good?
It says not irradiated to if I went like pills instead.
What dose would you recommend to replace two tablespoons of ground turmeric?
The brands I was considering were India organic, curcuclear, premium research, PRL brand has a ground turmeric.
But it's very pricey.
Yeah, well any of the firms that you buy can be contaminated. The benefit of buying from a good supplement company is they test all their their core products.
You know, and India organic India.
I think they do a good job testing premium research is very anal. They're testing the curcuclear isn't designed for health product that they're very anal with their testing to.
Oh excuse me.
So going with a good quality supplement company, you know you're going to get a free test and it's not going to have any garbage and you don't worry about it.
But you pay for it.
So it is going to be more expensive.
How much what is the milligram dosage of two tablespoons of ground turmeric?
I don't know.
You might be able to find that information on Google, but I don't I don't know what the answer to that is.
And I don't know if Star West Botanicals is a good product or not.
But can see if it's organic.
I don't know how well they test their stuff.
I wish I had a better answer for you.
On Saturday, the 16th, I began to have watery bubbly 10 diarrhea.
Sorry.
It extreme fatigue.
I see a lack of that effect.
It extreme gloat.
The only thing I could choke down is mashed potatoes.
So this question that you asked this person asked last week.
But now they says they put it to doctor twice.
They've got some testing done.
The culture showed more vanilla.
So more vanilla.
More vanilla is a is a gram negative bacteria.
So, which my doctor said has been lying dormant in my system.
From the pink line I had for chemo.
Oh.
He of course was going to prescribe antibiotics.
The thought it worth a try to heal it naturally first since I've been on so many interventions.
I'm also very low in potassium from the concept diarrhea.
I've been taking some proffetti probiotic enzymes.
A binder and charcoal against.
Sense Monday night.
I felt terrible on Monday.
Much better yesterday and low again today.
Do you have any suggestions?
How to tweak things?
I'm doing as well as other things that might help.
And what should I have the right for diarrhea?
No, I would run bacteria programs.
So I would run infection programs bacteria programs and pretty sure there's not.
Program for more vanilla.
I don't think there is.
But that's what those things I would run.
It's a bacteria, though, so you have to kill it.
The only thing you mentioned that you.
That you're taking that would probably help.
Um, would be charcoal.
Um, so charcoal can be effective against bacteria.
So.
But you might want to bump the dose and jump on it a little bit.
So you also think what are you going to do to help kill bacteria?
Well, burberry is a good thing to help kill bacteria.
Garlic is a good thing to help kill bacteria.
Um, so those would be the things that could be bacteria killers in the gut.
That's what I would consider is.
Is a burberry.
Garlic charcoal.
That's what I would do and run.
I would run a diarrhea program.
I would run bacteria.
I run infection.
Um, that's what I would run.
I'm going to get a pet scan to make sure I'm clear now that.
I'm done with my surgery.
My reconstruction was January.
I want to ease my mind so I can move forward confidently.
I haven't been scanned with a CT since February 2023.
It had an MRI pre mastectomy on September 2023.
So does that seem like a reasonable plan?
Yeah, I do.
Um, so yeah, I think that's a very reasonable plan.
Dr. Jens has to take 100 milligrams melatonin.
And two to 4,000 milligrams, like so we'll see a hour or two prior to the scan to help protect for radiation.
Um, yeah, that's fine.
I think that's fine too.
I have both your MRI and CT holyopathics, which one of these do you take for a scan?
So not the MRI holyopathic, the CT holyopathic.
So with your, with the pet scan, you're dealing not dealing with.
Yeah, the lidium because that's what the MRI holyopath is.
This is Catalidium is the MRI contrast.
A pet scan is going to be radiation.
So that's what you want to protect yourself against.
Um, is there anything else I need to know in order to avoid these false positives or mitigate the side effects of a scan?
Well, I don't think you have side effects on the pet scan.
I don't think you need to worry about that.
And, um, as far as false positives on the pet scan.
I don't think you need to be concerned about that either.
Um, where you see false positives is on an MRI or a CT scan when you already know you have a mass.
And, um, the false positive would be the false enlargement.
Or pseudo enlargement of a mass when it's just in a planetary response, killing that cancer.
So that's not going to be a concern either.
Yeah, get that done and let's get the results back and see what that looks like that will be interested in.
Any other questions?
Any thoughts on those two lumps?
So if the pet scan lights up at those two lumps, then you have to make a decision whether you're going to go ahead with.
But they'll call this is going to recommend is either surgery to remove those if they're seeing barely accessible or radiation.
Um, you already did, you know, conventional methods.
Um, you know, so I don't know that I would be against.
You know, moving forward if you felt confident and you felt, you know, you've confident what the oncologist is going to recommend.
So I would get their advice.
I'll gladly chat with you about it.
Yes, I'm doing surgery, but the other treatment.
From an alternative perspective.
Um, I would change anything the only thing I don't remember last time we did a cheap swap or something like that if we want to recheck supplements.
But you're still doing things to help your body, you know, cancer, the better if it's raising it, it's up the head or it's in remission or.
Um, you're still doing everything you're doing, make sure you, you know, continually with the rise.
Um, so I, I, you know, the only thing would be just tweaking things.
So if we have to tweak, there's anything specific like, oh, you have, you know, cancer in these two spots, so we definitely need to add this.
No, so we need to just tweak through a cheap swap and see if there's any changes that we need to make.
Um, that would be the only thing for them.
Would any inflammation still present after the surgery show up in a headscan?
Um, the answer that is yes and no, so if they won't do a pet scan, you know, within at least at least 30 days after surgery.
And some practitioners won't do it for three months after surgery.
Um, because your, when your body is healing from something, yes, you're going to have an increase metabolic activity and you can show up.
There can be some, some, uh, you know, increase in, um, pet scan activity, it's going to light up.
And it's going to be a false positive. They'd take that in consideration because it would be right at the scar or something like that.
That's just, that, that just doesn't happen. Usually that calms down within a week or two, honestly.
So I'd highly doubt that that's going to be an issue at this point, post surgery.
I have a lesion still left in my hip, but all else is clear.
Oh, uh, he's both few weeks ago, didn't he?
They may do low dose radiation as with my glucose cannot do any more chemo for now.
What do you think about that? Well, partly depends on where it is in your hip too.
So if it's at a weight-bearing issue, so there could be bone coverable and possible pathological fracture that I would say for sure I would go ahead with the radiation because the worst thing that could happen is having a pathological fracture fracture on the weight-bearing element of your bone.
You don't want that, but if it's not in a site that is going to be an issue with that is lots of folds that are weight-bearing per se.
And when you say your pelvis is in the ilium or ishium, you know, those are weight-bearing bones, but if it's in the acetabulum, well, then yeah, you're going to have weight from the femur head that's going to be it.
So the iliac, the iliac crest area is where the lesion is.
It just depends if it's a really small lesion, I mean, you might want to just try to heal that naturally and not do any more radiation.
So I do think radiation really shines best when you're doing it to bone, that's where you really see the best benefits.
There's anything that is a without issue when you're doing any radiation of your body.
If you're not having pain, it's not causing any issues, I maybe would keep an eye on it.
But you know, discuss it with the radiation oncologist if they think just a few sessions is going to knock it out because it's a real small spot, then I might reconsider that.
Any other questions?
All right, well, we will call it for tonight. Thanks for being on and we'll see everybody next week.
All right, bye-bye.